self-described as the number one
greatest show in las vegas history
absent celebrating its 10th anniversary
here to talk a little bit more about
that brock radke from las vegas weekly
nice to see you again brock how are you
doing
hey i'm great wonderful okay so brock
we've done
many many interviews over the years with
the filthy
mouse gazillionaire but for those not
familiar
how would you describe absence appeal
i think the great thing about absinthe
is that no matter what is happening in
this show
whether it's the gazillionaire saying
things that we can't repeat
on the news or some uh incredible
acrobatic act
everything that happens you're going to
want to tell somebody about you leave
that
tent and you are excited and you want to
share this experience with somebody
ah very good way to put it yes and it's
definitely an adult show too we want to
let people know
definitely 18 and over for sure um you
mentioned the tent brock and uh your
article traces the show's history
back to its debut in las vegas obviously
we all
associate it with the tent but didn't
realize that the first offer
was at a different resort property yeah
when the show
the show originated in new york actually
and when it was on tour
in 2008 in miami the producers
struck a deal with the owners of the
fountain blue hotel in miami
they were building the fountain blue in
las vegas at the time and
they completed a deal to have absent be
the opening
headlining show at fountain blue las
vegas of course we know how that story
went that hotel
never opened so the show had to find a
different home
and that's where caesar's palace came in
got it makes good sense well
that is caesar's palace gain of course
now um absence production company
spiegelworld has been pushing to get
shows reopened during this time no doubt
be many changes to the show's format to
make it socially distanced
yeah it's currently running right now
that tent usually
holds more than 600 people right now
it's about 160 i think
they've changed the seating arrangement
they've changed where the stage is
and they're hoping that restrictions are
going to continue to loosen up so that
they can
gradually increase the capacity of the
show all right and does spiegelworld
have other productions
in the works here in our area they do
they have two other shows
that have been running on the strip for
a while now and atomic saloon show at
the venetian
is going to reopen on may 5th okay well
that's great to know
all right um and i think we had them in
uh they were a duo pair and they had
very interesting things going on on the
set with special things behind the doors
and
they really took viewers into the
experience am i correct
that's a great show and it's really cool
to be able for that show to be able to
reopen in its actual venue which feels
like an
old wild west saloon done vegas style so
that's going to be a lot of fun to come
back very cool brock radke thank you so
very much of course everybody pick up
las vegas weekly's edition
for the week and we'll check back in
with you in the not too distant future